ARJAN DIJIK: Welcome, everybody.
Quickly introducing
myself, I'm Arjan.
I work in marketing.
And I'm delighted today that
we have Lord Browne here.
And I had the honor--
probably in May this year--
to meet him personally--
LORD JOHN BROWNE: That's right.
ARJAN DIJIK: --in London, just
before your book was released.
And I read the book,
actually, and I really
recommend to everybody,
if you haven't done so,
to read the book.
Because it is really
the kind of LGBT
lean in-- you might
not like this analogy--
but I thought it was
really well researched.
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
Sheryl may not like it.
ARJAN DIJIK: Sheryl
might not like it.
But it was really
well researched.
There was really a lot of things
were in there that I said, hmm,
I didn't know that.
And I really enjoyed it.
And Lord Browne, of course,
can introduce himself.
I will say a couple of things.
He was 13 years, I
think, CEO of BP.
I don't have to explain
BP to anybody of you.
I think the share price
quintupled, if that's English.
I think that's English.
So that's pretty amazing.
And so that all sounds really
all very nice and great.
But I think at the end
of your tenure, suddenly,
you were very publicly
outed as a gay man
by the wonderful UK papers.
I don't know if there's
anybody here from the UK.
But if you want to get
depressed, you know,
it's a guilty pleasure.
I do, when you're in the
British Airways lounge,
you read the "Daily Mail."
I don't know if you've
ever read the "Daily Mail,"
but you really
don't want to live.
It's really quite sharp
and quite negative.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: I think
it's tamed itself a bit,
compared with the past.
ARJAN DIJIK: Yeah, probably.
And so the idea is really
that we start off, maybe,
with a couple of
questions that I prepared.
But the whole idea
is, you know, it's
a Google Talk that
anybody of you
can really ask him a question.
Also, he has done already
two talks in Google-- one
in London and one in New York.
So clearly, Lord
Browne will have
an opinion on what Google is.
And we sometimes think
that we're terrific.
I sometimes think that.
So are we really that terrific?
What could we do better?
Are we great at LGBT inclusion?
What about diversity?
And I'm sure you have a
lot of ideas around it.
But maybe a kickoff with
a very easy question.
So why did you write the book?
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
Well, good afternoon.
I wrote the book for a
few very simple reasons.
The first is-- and today
is a very important day.
I just was looking at
the list of our people
who are running significant
corporations around the world,
and I took the S&P
list, and I had
to go down to S&P number 723,
I think it was at the time,
before I found an out gay CEO.
And I thought that's
statistically unusual.
Why is there only one person
in the top, let's say, 750
companies, who's out and gay?
That got changed today
when Tim Cook came out.
So there are now
two, which is great.
But one very significant one.
We'll come back to that.
Secondly, I thought
to myself, I really
didn't want anyone to go through
the same experience as I did.
Thirdly, I thought
that, and I knew
that, in my own
experience, you can
talk to people about what to do,
how to think about themselves.
But the best way
of demonstrating it
is to find role
models that people
can identify with and find
a little piece of themselves
in it to give them
confidence to be themselves,
to come out, to behave in an
authentic way in business.
And finally, I wrote this book
to send a great big letter
to the straight people
of the world, and said,
it's time that we
redoubled efforts
to make inclusion of LGBT
people a big priority.
And I gave them some
tips on how they'd do it.
And I really focused it on the
leadership of corporations.
The book's about corporations,
because I haven't been--
I'm not a football player.
I'm not an artist.
I'm not in different walks of
life with different problems
and issues.
I'm a business person,
so I talk about business.
ARJAN DIJIK: Yeah.
And as a CEO of BP-- you
were there 13 years--
you clearly had made it.
The company was doing
incredibly well.
How much more was
there to gain for you?
So why didn't you come out?
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
Well, because I was
used to being in the closet.
I mean, it's an
amazingly trivial answer
to a complex question.
You have to go
back to my history.
And some of it is
now irrelevant,
but the outcome may
be very relevant.
So I built myself two lives.
And the reason I did that is
that when I could understand
my sexuality, it was
actually illegal to do
any homosexual act in
the UK, and in most
of the states of the
United States of America.
So it was a dangerous
position to be in.
You could be blackmailed,
you could be threatened,
you could be bullied.
So I said, I think I'll
keep that to myself.
And secondly, I
came from a family
with my mother, who was a
survivor of the Holocaust--
survivor of Auschwitz.
And her couple of tips for
life, very strongly held,
were, first, if you've got a
secret, don't tell anybody,
because it's no longer a
secret if you tell one person.
And secondly, just be
careful about being
a member of a minority,
because minorities are always
punished when the going
gets tough for the majority.
And actually, in her
experience, that's
exactly what she identified.
So for me, it was a
pretty convincing case
that I had to keep
two lives separate.
When I was doing
this in my 20s, it
felt exciting and interesting.
It's like being
James Bond, you know?
You have a legend,
and you have reality,
and you must never
let them meet.
And so I built this huge
edifice of two lives,
and I got used to it.
And I believe that as I was
getting more senior-- actually,
as I was in business-- I thought
that if people knew I was gay,
I'd lose supplier respect,
I'd lose customers,
I wouldn't be able to deal
with foreign governments,
and my peers would make fun of
me, and they'd think I'm weak.
So I kept it to myself.
And strangely, you know, because
there were no role models
around, I didn't notice
the world changing,
and I just kept those fears
in my head to the very end.
And that's why I was outed
by a former boyfriend.
A much more complex
story, but I was
outed in the "Daily
Mail" group newspapers
on the 1st of May, 2007.
ARJAN DIJIK: And before we
go into that-- trust me,
I have a couple of
difficult questions,
but we're doing
the softballs now--
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
This is a warm-up.
ARJAN DIJIK: This is a warm-up.
If I look at myself--
not to talk about myself,
but everybody likes
talking about themselves--
I came out late, you know?
What happened is that
probably in my 20s,
I was extremely focused
on work, because I didn't
go through the kind of
normal relationships, ups
and downs, the kind of
focusing on your personal life.
So it meant, actually, that
I progressed my career,
for my age, incredibly fast.
So would you have been CEO of
BP if you-- It's a catch-22.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: It's
a hypothetical question.
ARJAN DIJIK: I know.
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
Because you never know.
Because what you take away,
you get on another basis.
So I was very
focused on my work.
I was probably obsessively
focused on my work
throughout my entire career.
That's also true.
And I didn't have
these relationships,
but I had a lot of
interference from trying
to get relationships
in a half-baked way.
Because you can't actually
have a relationship
if you're only half a person.
It's rather difficult
to make that work.
And I think in work, I
think what I became--
a friend of mine in the
city here, San Francisco,
said to me-- she's a lesbian,
a bisexual woman-- she said,
"Well, I always knew there
was something wrong with you,
because even as an Englishman,
you redefined the word
'reserved.'"
And that was my protection.
I just didn't engage
on any personal matter
with people at work.
And as a result, I was
regarded with-- while I
think people followed me,
I think they followed me
with a high degree of
concern that no one could
see behind the veil.
There was a lot going on
which no one could see,
and I didn't let them see.
ARJAN DIJIK: So that's
very interesting.
And now, getting to the
more difficult ones.
So you're a very
smart businessman.
You've been very successful.
You're very good
at assessing risks.
So you start a relationship
with a 24-year-old escort.
That sounds like risky to me.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Well,
so here's the thing.
I think, certainly,
conducting a life like mine,
I think it's taught me how
to read people very quickly
and how to be
dynamically positioned
and how to understand
people quite well.
But here's the logic.
This is the mad logic.
So I got to a very
senior position in BP,
and I know it's
the oil business,
but I was very visible, and
I was very recognizable.
Wherever I went, people
would recognize who I was.
Because at the
time, BP, I think,
was the third largest
company in the world.
So I decided that
logically, therefore,
I couldn't go out
to meet somebody.
But I wanted to have somebody.
So the answer was the safety
of an escort website, which
I thought was obviously
very safe, because I didn't
have to tell anyone about it.
So that was judgment
error number one.
Number two error, because
all errors come in threes,
was to meet someone, I actually
believed that a person I met
in that way, I could
build a relationship with,
which I couldn't.
And the third error
of judgment was
to have a cover story
about how I met him,
and to believe that I could
maintain that story even
as I was going to court to
prevent this story being
published.
So I actually lied in
a witness statement,
which I corrected very
quickly, because I
couldn't believe I'd done it.
So someone-- I think
probably my inner self
slapped me in the
face and said stop it.
So three errors of
judgment in a row.
ARJAN DIJIK: I think there's a
fourth one, if you don't mind.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: No, please.
ARJAN DIJIK: Which is
you hired a top law firm.
So, shouldn't you have
hired a top PR firm?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: I did both.
ARJAN DIJIK: Oh, you did both?
OK.
It's not in your book.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Well,
so I hired a top law firm.
In 2006, it was all
the rage to have--
all the rage-- it was
fashionable, I think,
for a lot of people to
have these so-called super
injunctions in the UK, which
you could stop people publishing
things which violated
your privacy.
Of course, the
"Daily Mail" group
argued that I
didn't have privacy,
because I was a public
figure, and therefore, it
was a matter of public
policy and interest
for them to know
everything about me.
It's an interesting point
that when you get right
on the top of a
company, you've probably
abrogated your privacy,
anyway, in today's terms.
But I fought this, and
I kept it bottled up.
I couldn't tell anyone
about it, because if I
told anyone what we were doing,
it was contempt of court.
So for four months,
we were battling
this case, which eventually
I lost on May the 1st.
I got permission to hire a
top PR firm, which I did,
to just maintain the storm.
All they said to me was this.
"There's not a lot we can do.
This is going to be terrible.
You just need to
toughen up your skin,
and you need to get used to it."
ARJAN DIJIK: I like
the quote in your book
was, "You know, when
the caravans move--"
LORD JOHN BROWNE: That
was another friend
of mine, a great, great
politician friend of mine who'd
been beaten up no end of times
used this quote from Joseph
Needham.
He's a great scientist,
sinologist, who said,
"When the--" so to finish
things off-- "the dogs bark,
and the caravan moves on."
It's absolutely true.
The dogs do bark, and
then the caravan moves on.
So I left BP on May the 1st.
It was May Day.
I thought that was
quite important.
And I decided that-- rather,
all the security people said,
you really need to leave the
building by the back entrance.
There were all sorts of
different escape entrances
from BP headquarters,
because there
were quite a lot of
protests from time to time
about the oil industry.
But I said, no,
I think I'm going
to walk through the front door.
Because I felt to myself
that I had rights, too.
So I walked through
the front door,
and I met the world's
press, and they
became my constant
companions for three days.
And people on motorbikes chasing
me with long telephoto lenses.
And after that,
they left me alone.
And so I just decided I
had to just redo my life.
So I did.
ARJAN DIJIK: Great.
So maybe one more
question about the book.
Are you happy with what
it has achieved so far?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: So
the purpose of the book
is to do what I said
at the beginning.
But in the end, it's not a book.
I want to maintain momentum for
great positive change that's
taking place that
is probably not,
I think, other than limited
and very important parts of it,
very limited areas,
there's still
a lot to do in the
corporate sector
to get people to feel
comfortable to be themselves.
And I say this by
the number of people
I've spoken to much
more of your age
than mine who have still
chosen, for reasons of concern,
to stay in the closet at work
but be out in private life.
And so I think I just observed
that this was going on.
And I felt also that
at the senior levels,
I noticed how the progress
of women in business
always had promise, and
never quite achieved
what it was expected to do.
I can speak very clearly
about the UK, where,
for example, there's been a big
push to put women on boards.
So there's 20% women as
non-executives on boards.
That's nice to have.
But the real
question is, how many
women on executive and
management committees
are there?
And the answer is only 6%
of management committees
are women.
So I said, if after
all that effort,
this is what we
achieved with women,
I think we've got to work
very hard to achieve something
with LGBT people.
And so the purpose of
the book's a movement,
and I'm happy that that's
beginning, you might say.
Sales of the book are
fine and all that stuff,
but that's not the
point, I'd say.
The point is what the book talks
about, not the book itself.
ARJAN DIJIK: And
in your book, you
quoted 41% of LGBT
executives in the USA
decide to stay in the
closet, and 34% in the UK.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Yeah.
ARJAN DIJIK: So the US
a bit worse than the UK.
Why do you think
it's still the case?
Because especially also
in the US, in most states,
you know-- I think there's some.
I'm not American, so I
will say stupid things.
But in most states, you
cannot be fired, you cannot--
what do you think?
Do you think that--
LORD JOHN BROWNE: I think
there's a very long shadow,
and I do think that-- I say to
people in London, here we are.
We're sitting in Chelsea
and Mayfair in London.
We sit in Shoreditch
and Notting Hill,
and everything looks fantastic.
I said, you want to travel
50 miles north out of London
and ask the question again?
It's very different.
I suggest the same here.
You want to travel east from
this place, 50, 100 miles,
it could be different.
You want to go to-- I mean,
I've worked all over the States.
I've worked in some really
exciting places like Cleveland,
Ohio, which I liked, actually.
But around Cleveland,
it's going to be
more difficult to be yourself
than it is in New York City
or in Mountain View or in
San Francisco or in Paris.
It'll be much more
difficult in Rome.
So there's a lot
of inconsistency,
and it's very easy for all of
us, I think, to think, right,
we're done.
Because I look around my 100
yards around me, and everyone's
fine.
But actually, the
world is much bigger
when you go outside
the US and Europe.
You really do see
some big issues.
In 77 countries, still,
it's a criminal act
to either promote or to
undertake homosexual acts.
In five of the countries,
it's the death penalty.
And it's not actually
getting better.
It's getting worse.
ARJAN DIJIK: And maybe
talking about it,
a lot of us who
have [? fret at ?]
the [? economy, ?] I
think of two weeks ago,
we talked about kind of
the extreme gay divide.
And it talked
about, more or less,
people going from
very tolerant, nice,
to kind of extremely
conservative.
Russia, Middle East, and then
you see, especially in the US,
for example, gay
marriage has really--
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Is taking off.
ARJAN DIJIK: Beyond belief.
Everybody could not
have hoped for more.
What can we do about
this, do you think?
As we work in Google.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Well,
you can't change-- I mean,
no corporation can get anyone
to change the law, really,
certainly outside
their home country.
And there they can
lobby, but it's usually
for business purposes.
I believe there is a business
purpose to LGBT inclusion.
It improves productivity,
apart from being
right on a values basis.
But I think what
you can do is you
can apply an economic nudge--
a big economic nudge, which
I think has worked, in
my own direct experience,
in environmental matters,
in transparency, payments
to governments, transparency,
in certain other human rights.
So CEOs can apply a
nudge to get change.
And interestingly, the most
important thing, I think,
is to, when you have
expatriate [INAUDIBLE] people,
to send out gay people
to a place like Uganda
as the CEO of a local
branch of Company
X. As long as they
don't break the law,
it's an amazing
signal, I believe.
And it's a signal of
equality, of real inclusion,
and I think a point being made
which is not for that purpose
alone-- because it's
about the company--
but it makes a point that a
company has a variety of people
doing great things
of great merit,
regardless of their background,
regardless of their sexuality.
ARJAN DIJIK: Yeah.
Great.
So I think maybe it's
time to go to Q&A. Medea
has the microphone, so if you
have a question, don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: My question is
if you have a point of view
on how well Silicon Valley
and the tech industry does.
In this space, I
think [INAUDIBLE]
is that tech is rather inclusive
compared to other industries.
But do you think we're
all the way there,
or is there more
of a ways to go?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: I
don't have, I think,
a knowledgeable analysis.
What I do observe,
though, is a lot
of statements about
the difficulties
in some parts of Silicon Valley,
including San Francisco, where
some companies have become more
frat house style companies.
And this has been bad for
all forms of inclusion, LGBT
being no exception,
women being no exception.
So I think, like
any organization,
you have to be very careful
to maintain a clear-eyed view
on inclusion, which means
that people don't get put
into a position of being
excluded inadvertently
or-- inadvertently, actually,
[? where ?] discrimination
is rare.
But inadvertent exclusion
by team activity
that doesn't allow
people to be themselves.
And I think that you have to
be very careful about that,
because enthusiasm can
take you to a place which
is negative as
opposed to positive.
So I see that as probably
the biggest danger.
AUDIENCE: So then,
just as a followup,
so you think the remedy, at
least on a micro level scale,
is to just be mindful of how
your team engages with one
another?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Generally.
I mean, I think, you
know, the formula
is a very
straightforward formula
about getting almost
anything done in business.
The leader has to say,
I want it to happen.
Secondly, managers
have to spend time
making it happen, which means
they've got to be encouraged,
directed, or incentivized
to put time on their agenda,
to talk to people and figure
out how to include people.
What to do to make it safe for
LGBT people to be themselves.
What to do to make sure that
men can interact with women
in a way which makes sense.
So time, and then measuring
that through surveys,
and then making sure that
you have the role models.
We've talked about that.
So signals from the top,
measurement, role models.
And finally, making sure that
inclusion means inclusion.
So it doesn't mean having
LGBT networks and saying,
well, we've got those.
That's great.
Tick.
Actually, it's about including
straight allies and everybody
in bigger networks.
The danger is simply
satisfying yourself
that you've done something
important by getting
all the people who are
just the same as each other
talking to each other,
and keeping it sealed up.
That's not right.
AUDIENCE: First of all, just
thank you for your candor.
It's been a really
wonderful talk so far.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I'm wondering
when you were still
heading up BP, did you
ever consider coming out?
Or was that just
never a possibility?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: You know,
I never thought about it,
because I'd so-- you
have to remember,
I'd been in the closet,
I suppose-- well,
I was 59 when I was outed.
So pick the date when I started.
13, let's say?
So that was a grand
total of 45 years.
By that time, I really
had persuaded myself
that my arguments
about not coming out
were absolutely perfect.
There was no question
that they were wrong.
Because after 45 years
of talking to yourself
about a topic, you're
bound to be right.
I mean, who is to
disagree with you?
So I'm trivializing it.
But these were
firmly held beliefs,
so it didn't even cross my mind.
Strangely, like everybody
in the position that I held,
when I go and talk
about my book and what
I believe is right to get
this movement moving right
across the world,
people say to me,
well, John, we
knew you were gay.
It's just that we felt that you
didn't want to hear from us,
and we kind of respected that.
So everybody knew I
was gay, apparently.
I mean, even in other
companies outside BP,
in the oil and gas sector.
A guy got up in--
I was presenting
at a literary festival,
Cheltenham Literary Festival.
And he got up and
said, well, you know,
we all knew you were
gay, but we just
couldn't bring ourselves
to say it to you.
And we just felt
it was very tragic
that you didn't know that.
But that happens.
It happens a lot.
People guard
themselves for safety.
No one ever does something, I
mean, really recklessly unsafe.
And I thought that was
recklessly unsafe, to come out.
If I can add, it will
be very interesting
and why I think Tim Cook
coming out is very important.
Again, a lot of people
said they knew he
was gay, been a lot of chatter.
But there's a very
big difference
if you're a leader to
actually come out and say,
I'm gay, and then elaborate.
And he, therefore, had
there been someone like him
around while I was CEO of
BP, or maybe another CEO
of a big company, I
might have said, hmm.
Well, if he can do it, so can
I. And it would have given me
a lot of confidence.
I might not have done it,
but it would have given me
much more confidence.
ARJAN DIJIK: And maybe,
for me to chip in, why do
you think it took him so long?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Coming
out is a process--
a unique process-- and everyone
has all kinds of barriers
or demons they've got to kill.
Barriers they've
got to overcome.
And actually, I've
noticed that one or two
CEOs of smaller companies who
are out before they become
a CEO, always kind of
go back into the closet
for a little while,
while they're a CEO,
and then come out again.
And it's because
the change of status
makes them feel that
they need to express
different priorities.
So I think everyone does that.
I've been very struck
by a lot of people,
younger people who work
with me, they always say,
well, we're gay.
And they say, well,
John, it's fine for you.
Everyone knows you're gay now.
We, on the other hand,
every time I change a job,
I have to come out.
And it's exhausting.
They say it's
absolutely exhausting.
So we need to figure
out how to make
coming out not as important.
ARJAN DIJIK: I'm sorry.
I know there are more
questions, but, so, what
is the advice you would give?
So how do you do that?
What would you advise to
someone who's in the closet
and is struggling to get out,
based on how you look at it?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Well,
from my own experience,
if I replay it all,
I'd say, first,
don't invest too much
time building two lives.
Because it is
negative investment,
and actually, it's difficult
to-- literally like
an investment-- it's very
difficult to write off,
as it were.
The more you build the edifice,
the more it's with you.
So the sooner you can come
out, the better, I think.
Secondly, but don't
do it recklessly.
You've got to be with an
employer who's made it safe
for you to do that.
Sending out the right signals,
the right encouragement,
the right networks.
Not just gay networks, but
gay and straight networks.
But you can't do it recklessly.
No one can be expected
to do it recklessly.
But I think there
are increasingly
employers who can do that.
And I'd go further
and say, actually,
if you find it
intolerable, leave
and find another employer
that will let you do this.
And I'm very struck
that-- and again, I've
interviewed people who were very
intrigued with what companies
were saying about LGBT inclusion
at these recruitment fairs.
And many of them
were straight women.
And they said, we go around
talking to the LGBT recruiters,
because we figured out that
if they get this right,
they probably get gender right.
So, leading indicator,
lagging indicator.
AUDIENCE: So the oil industry
has a lot of aspects of it
in the companies
where they can be
kind of an all boys
culture, very conservative.
What advice would you
give to someone struggling
with the decision to come
out in that industry,
and also to someone who
wants to be an ally working
in that culture?
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
So I think one thing
I did when I came out in a
rather spectacular way-- I was
out in a spectacular
way-- was to change
some mindsets somewhere.
So my old company,
BP, for example,
is doing very well in this area.
They're very concerned.
They're very, very
concerned about making sure
that LGBT inclusion is
deeply in the agenda.
And they've done it very well.
Two members of the executive
management committee
are out gay people.
Their global head of
HR and the global head
of supply trading,
which is the place where
90% of the revenue
of BP is generated.
So it's not exactly a small job.
So this is great.
And they will say,
well, we went back
and thought about what
on Earth was going on,
and they did something about it.
So I think more
and more people are
feeling comfortable to come
out in that environment.
They're very concerned
about making sure
that it's not a
barrier to most people,
or send people to Russia, or--
You know, there are plenty of
places the oil industry works
which is where a lot of
other companies don't.
West Africa, lots of
places, the Middle East.
And they're doing that.
They're absolutely doing that.
So I think there are
one or two companies.
And there are other companies.
I mean, it's well known that,
I think, on the HRC Index,
Exxon is the only company
that, for three years,
has had a negative score.
So it's made of extremes.
It's made of extremes.
I think gone are the days--
when I joined the oil industry,
there were hardly any
women in the oil industry.
There was an event, I remember,
even in the United States,
where I worked.
The event was having a
woman engineer arrive,
and having to find a space
to make a women's lavatory.
But things have changed a lot.
So I think that that sort of--
how I managed to tolerate it,
I'm not quite sure, but you
just get used to things.
But it's an overly exclusive
good old boys' network
for this, I think, in these
big companies, has changed.
In small companies, I
still think it's just
like that in the oil industry.
ARJAN DIJIK: And
maybe related to that
is that a little
anecdote from Google.
A very senior colleague
of mine, female,
is in Hollywood-- a big
studio, a big meeting-- there's
a big Hollywood film boss.
There are guys,
there are some women.
And then he says to her, hey,
honey, pour me some coffee.
So imagine, if that
happens, what do you do?
Because I don't think that
blatant discrimination
is the issue.
It's always the kind of stuff
that you say, do I now really--
but you're in a kind
of partner meeting.
This is not within the company.
So there is clearly some
business to be done.
How principled-- how
would you deal with that?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: I think you
need to be very principled.
Because people observe you.
You always observe behavior
in the more difficult
circumstances.
It's easy to be perfect
when there are no issues.
It's tough to be even
half perfect when
there are big challenges.
It doesn't matter what it is.
They always test you
and they observe.
They watch.
So if you say to
people, I really
want to be an
inclusive organization,
and the first thing you do
is go out and be exclusive,
then people say,
well, this is a joke.
This is a joke.
So you've got to be consistent.
So I like the IBM
approach, which is,
they say, look, people
behave like that,
we don't want them with
suppliers or customers.
And I believe
they're pretty close.
And BP is the same.
Now, they have to go
with their eyes open.
You know, you go to
Abu Dhabi and Dubai,
or go to [INAUDIBLE],
and you know
the rules you're
undertaking, which
is it's illegal there for people
to undertake homosexual acts,
period.
It's not illegal to be gay.
It's different.
And therefore, you can behave
correctly and appropriately,
but you shouldn't take
any discrimination
or any pejorative words.
I mean, you occasionally
have to educate people.
I was very struck in
my own private equity
firm-- I'm a partner of
a private equity firm.
We had this meeting of CEOs
of some of our portfolio
companies, where they sold
half their company, or we
[INAUDIBLE] out of some
[? of our ?] investment,
and so they'd made quite a
lot of money, these people,
correctly.
And so there were a panel,
and one of my partners
was chairing a panel.
And they said, what's it
feel like when you go home
and tell the wife that
you've made all this money?
So I look at the audience.
I'm sitting there.
And first of all, the
number of limited partners,
investors, represented
by women, not that many
in private equity.
But there are some.
And I notice one or two of
them wince a little bit.
But they're kind of used to
it in that sort of milieu,
but inappropriate.
So afterwards, I went
up to the guy and said,
well, you know, I want you
to know that I'm not sure
how my partner, who's a
man, would think about this.
And he said, I got it.
He said, I just-- I'm so sorry.
No one had ever
told me about this.
No one ever told me about it.
And I think a lot of it is
a little bit of education.
People are generally
pretty smart,
and they've generally
got great common sense.
And just a bit of
education to say,
don't be politically correct.
Just be commonsensical.
Just use your common sense.
And it goes a very
long way, I think.
AUDIENCE: Research
shows that companies
that are led by
diverse leadership
perform better financially.
But it's kind of [INAUDIBLE].
It's kind of
unclear whether it's
because it's like an indicator
of a good management team,
or is it because people
are able to be themselves,
more and more productive?
So this is kind of
hypothetical, but have you
thought about how it would have
been if you were out at BP?
And can you address,
like, what are the reasons
that these companies
perform better?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: So there's
a lot of work in this area.
Some of it's a little suspect,
because the data analysis
is not there.
But some of the
really good work is
this-- that people
have simply divided
their 20 years worth of staff
surveys, employee surveys.
So they've gone around
and divided companies
into those which have high
engagement scores against those
who have low engagement scores.
On these surveys,
they're consistent data.
And they compared the financial
performance of these two data
sets.
Those with high
performance engagement
consistently outperformed
those with low engagement
by around about 2% a year
over a 20-year period.
It's fantastic.
Huge, huge outperformance.
Huge outperformance.
Now, engagement-- the most about
engagement is about inclusion.
And if you get inclusion
right, then engagement follows.
If-- and it's pretty
obvious, really,
that if you don't have
people who are engaged,
they're using their
mind for something else.
Or in the reverse,
they're using their mind
to be someone they're not, and
therefore they can't engage.
So I think engagement
produces a very significant,
and therefore, inclusion, of
all sorts, including LGBT,
produce outsized
financial returns.
There's a second
dimension, which
is when you make a
decision, you really
do want people to
come at a decision
from different points of view.
Otherwise, again, you're
persuading yourself
that you're absolutely perfect,
and you know all the answers.
And therein lies real danger.
And that's where
corporations fail.
So having diverse management
teams at all levels
is really very important.
That diversity is generated
many different ways,
depending on the company
you're involved in.
If you're in a
resource company, you
want to make absolutely sure
you've got representative.
You've understood
how you can include,
for example, a simple
thing like people
from the country in
which you're working.
That was a novel
idea a long time ago.
And if you're
marketing something,
then surely you
want to understand
the impact and the
understanding of people
from different race backgrounds,
different sexualities,
you name it.
So I think there's lots of
different ways of creating
diversity in decision making.
But I come back saying
if you get LGBT inclusion
right, chances you've got all
sorts of other inclusion right,
because it's one of the more
difficult things to consider.
Especially when
it requires-- you
have to get inclusion
right in order
to get people to self-disclose
that they're gay in order
to get inclusion right.
So if you think about it,
it's a multistage process,
whereas other things are
a single stage process.
Sorry.
I'm an engineer, so I
need to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I actually
have three questions.
The first one being that if
you knew then all the things
that you know now, would
you change your experience
with resigning from BP?
Would you have let everything
play out as it did,
or would there have been things
that you would have changed?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: So
I think at the time,
it was very clear to me that
I had to resign from BP,
because the circumstances
were unusual.
I knew that the press
would go after me,
and I didn't want
BP to suffer that.
In particular, I'd invested a
lot of my life in this firm,
and I just didn't want people
to be damaged in that way.
So it was very clear to me that
this was my responsibility.
And I had to get
control of my life.
And the way to control
it is to take an action,
and it was very clear
that the action was
to resign, not
just from BP, but I
tried to resign from
everything I was involved in.
Some people simply
refused to accept it,
because I thought we'd
just start again, really.
Why not start again?
And so I think the
decision was right.
Today, I think I'd have to think
about it in the circumstances.
In [INAUDIBLE],
my answers change
as the information changes.
So I think now it would
depend on the circumstances.
But I think it would
be easier, probably,
to say, well, I'll
just fight it.
I'll just carry on.
I think when every year goes
by, I think it will get easier.
AUDIENCE: And since
leaving BP, have you ever
been brought back
in as a consultant?
And if so, have
there been any advice
that you've provided, like,
culturewise to the company?
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
No, I haven't been
invited back up until recently.
So, first of all, I do
not believe in-- in fact,
I hate the idea of former CEOs
coming back into a company
and saying, well,
you know, in my day,
or this is a much better
way of doing things.
Even worse, actually
commenting on the outside.
I don't approve of that, either.
Because the person in charge
is the person in charge.
And they say, the king is dead.
Long live the king.
So it's gone.
Its very ephemeral.
And so I don't approve of that.
I actually-- it took me five
years to go into the building,
back into the BP building.
And I was invited in not
by my successor, because he
was let go after the Gulf
spill, but his successor, who
also used to be my executive
assistant when I was a CEO.
And he said, come and have
lunch on July the 4th.
BP's open for business.
So I went into the
building on July the 4th
and had lunch and met everybody.
It was very nice.
And then I didn't go
back again until I
was invited by BP to come and
talk about "The Glass Closet."
And then I was invited
in, for those of you
with historical perspectives,
on Bastille Day.
Seems very appropriate
at the moment.
The start of the revolution.
It was just right.
And so I was invited in
and interviewed, amazingly,
by a rather wonderful
straight man who
also used to be my executive
assistant now in charge
of all the production
operations at BP.
So he interviewed me, and
it was done, because BP is
like Google, in lots of places.
We did it in the media
center, and it was
transmitted all over the world.
So that was rather good.
And a lot of change.
It would have been
difficult to imagine
inviting in any gay man,
let alone the former CEO,
to BP eight years ago
to do such a thing.
ARJAN DIJIK: You had
three questions, you said?
AUDIENCE: Right.
One last one.
It's a little silly.
You did mention earlier
Cleveland, Ohio,
and your experience
working there.
How did you feel about them
hosting the Gay Games earlier
this year?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: Well,
I was invited to them,
and I couldn't make it.
I used to work for the Standard
Oil Company, Ohio, there.
I was in the
Standard Oil Company.
And one of the people
who used to work for me
is actually the president of
the Gay Games for the year.
But I just couldn't make it.
The timing was all wrong.
But I think it was terrific.
AUDIENCE: What
advice would you get
to a young person at
a company that they
felt like their career was
being stifled in some way
by being out?
Would you say you should
go to a company that's
more open to that?
Let's say Google.
Or they should stay?
Because an analogy can be
drawn for people in states
like Alabama, for example.
So, should all the
gay people in Alabama
just move to San
Francisco and New York?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But in a
way, Alabama is never
going to make progress if
gay people keep leaving,
in the same way
corporations that
are unfriendly to gay people are
never going to make progress.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: I think it
depends on your future view,
doesn't it?
It depends on whether you
can see any progress at all.
But, I mean, if it's
going backwards,
then I'd suggest walking out
and doing something else,
if you really do believe
nothing will change.
But actually, a lot
of these places,
you can see some
elements of change.
So if you think you can see
it and you can be part of it,
then stick with it.
I do think it's important
that individuals
try, insofar as possible, to
control their own destiny.
There's nothing--
well, there are
plenty of bad things in life.
But one bad thing is
to feel that you're out
of control of your own destiny.
You know, someone is
pushing you around
or doing something that doesn't
allow you to be yourself.
But if you can see
changing that, then stay.
If you can't, go.
But it's an interesting
mind experiment
to think of all the people from
Alabama going to both coasts.
It would be extraordinary.
AUDIENCE: So you could argue
that it's relatively easy
for us, working at Google,
living in San Francisco
or Shoreditch.
At the same time, we
have a great platform
to reach millions of
people, billions of people.
What can we do to help?
What is your message for us?
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
Well, I think you
can, because information and
little things like role models.
And one of the reasons I
put together this little--
founded this website,
glasscloset.org--
it's not huge.
But it's designed to
aggregate role model stories
so that people can talk and see.
So it's sort of getting this
information out, getting people
to talk to each other.
These things are very
important indeed.
What is very
surprising is who gets
to read the stuff outside
the UK and the USA.
And the answer is, a
lot of places where it's
illegal to do anything gay.
People want to read it, because
they see in these stories
an aspiration that they'd like
to hold that things could be
different, and that actually,
they could be different
themselves, and maybe
they can make a change.
So I think Google can
participate in this hugely.
Hugely.
Because it does have the
footprint of the world.
And the world also includes
places in the United States
where it's tough.
Also, places outside London and
Manchester where it's tough.
Also places outside
Paris, and so forth.
But also in places like
Saudi Arabia, and in Uganda,
and now, I see Singapore, where
the supreme court has just
reversed certain
rulings to, again,
make it illegal to
undertake homosexual acts.
ARJAN DIJIK: Well, I
think we're wrapping up.
Maybe two short questions
with very short answers,
which is you've been in
three locations at Google.
What did you like worst?
What disappointed you?
And it can't be my t-shirt.
LORD JOHN BROWNE:
It's not the t-shirt,
and it's not the coffee, either.
And certainly not
the food, I must say.
I think the worst-- I think it's
that we met in internal rooms,
with the single
exception of this.
And I think this is a rather
wonderful room to meet in.
It sounds trivial, but
it's very oppressive
to meet in dark rooms.
ARJAN DIJIK: Dark rooms.
Yeah.
And then the best thing,
to end on a positive note?
LORD JOHN BROWNE: You know,
I think the best thing is
every time I look at
an audience in Google,
people are very interested.
And what is surprising--
maybe there's a rule here--
but I was warned in
New York and London
that multitasking was
the name of the game,
and that I should expect
people to be listening to me,
but actually doing
something else.
I haven't seen that happen here.
ARJAN DIJIK: Minimally.
I think minimally.
LORD JOHN BROWNE: I think
it's rather wonderful.
And I take it as
an important thing.
So thank you.
ARJAN DIJIK: Wonderful.
Well, thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]